[Music]
the 84 year old woman last week who won
the largest ever lottery prize in the
United States versus 370 million dollars
in the 84 year old woman
unbelievable incredible story well one
of our local late night sponsors has
already jumped right on this story and
there I guess based on this story and
they're already offering a new service
check it out hey folks ivanov cameron
well so i thought i'd warm up with six
how you doing hey doing how you doing
how you doing I adore and I adore now
you're going is that six hello Powerball
winning octogenarians
are you between the ages of 1889 and
have you recently come into possession
of between 300 and 400 million dollars
then you're probably asking yourself I
mean come on sorry but come on that's a
lot of dough in very little time
we're smacking smacking super-expensive
funeral directors and what better way to
spend all of your money on yourself than
with a ridiculously lavish funeral what
are you gonna do buy gold oatmeal maybe
you can get some gold Oh Camille we got
buy gold old male bytecode oatmeal
oatmeal that's gold no such things gold
oh man we have I thought oh man it'll
make me gold oatmeal of such kind of
oatmeal all of them what are you doing
leader wealthiest stupid grandkids
anyway we've got everything you need for
lavish plot all the stops funerals first
off your body will be dipped in gold it
will then be placed in an ancient
Egyptian sarcophagus which will then be
placed in a submarine which will then be
dipped in gold which will then be placed
in a huge corporate man at a vintage
baseball cards and who better to carry
the coffin than the top 500 CEOs of
Fortune 500 companies today at your
funeral
the rolling stones with special guests
Prince Paul McCartney's sting and Kanye
West's that's like for
for Kanye's be perfect probably not
what is this don't worry about it your
funeral will be practiced on all major
networks posted by Ryan Seacrest on the
back of a genetically engineered t-rex
the other principal funerals is three
hundred and fifty million dollars
we're know what you're thinking how can
two disbarred attorneys who used to
specialize in gay divorce possibly be
trusted with this kind of money don't
worry about it just off route 9 in the
premise
[Applause]
[Music]